PROGRAM. THIS SPACE RACE. OUR
NEXT GUEST HAS BEEN AT THE VERY
FOREFRONT PAM MELROY IS DEPUTY
ADMINISTRATOR OF NASA AND A
FORMER ASTRONAUTS, ONE OF ONLY
TWO WOMEN TO COME ON TO SPACE
SHUTTLE ALSO, SHE'S A FORMER
MILITARY COMBAT THE PILOT, AND
SHE'S LOGGED MORE THAN 38 DAYS
IN SPACE THE US MADE MORE THAN
100 SPACE LAUNCHES LAST YEAR,
MORE THAN CHINA, MORE THAN
RUSSIA. BUT ITS MOON MISSIONS
HAVE HAD A STRING OF SETBACKS
AND DELAYS. I ASKED MELROY
WHERE THIS LEAVES THE UNITED
STATES WHEN SHE JOINED ME FROM
NASA HQ IN WASHINGTON PAM
MELROY, WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM
>> THANK YOU. CHRISTIANE, I'M A
FAN AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
OUR CONVERSATION.
>> THANK YOU. WELL, I'M A HUGE
SPACE FAN. I TO WATCH THE MOON
WALK APOLLO. APOLLO 11. CAN I
JUST ASK YOU THIS THOUGH? ALL
WE IN ANOTHER SPACE RACE FOR 50
YEARS IT'S THE UNITED STATES
DOMINATED. AND NOW WITH THE
PRIVATE ENTERPRISE COMING INTO
THE SPACE, TRAVEL, THE SPACE
EXPLORATION, WE SAW JUST
RECENTLY A VERY HYPED SPACE
SPACE X STARSHIPS BLOWING UP
AFTER TAKEOFF IN THE US LAST
YEAR, NASA WAS HOPING THAT
THESE WOULD REALLY BE, YOU
KNOW, SOME PIONEERING VOYAGES.
WE SEE THAT. AND THEN WE HEARD
THE ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THE
ARTEMIS MISSION TO ORBIT THE
MOON IS GOING TO BE DELAYED AND
THEN NEXT, ARTEMIS MISSION TO
LAND ON THE MOON FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN DECADES, IS GOING TO BE
FURTHER DELAYED. AT THE SAME
TIME COUNTRIES LIKE INDIA,
CHINA, JAPAN, OR HAVING
NATIONAL CELEBRATIONS ABOUT
THEIR SUCCESSES. DOES THIS
WORRY YOU
>> OH, NOT IN THE LEAST. WE
HAVE PLENTY OF OUR OWN
SUCCESSES. AND I THINK THAT'S
EVIDENCED REALLY WE HAVE THE
ONLY VEHICLE THAT IS CURRENTLY
CAPABLE OF TAKING HUGE WOMEN'S
TO DEEP SPACE. WE'RE THE ONLY
ONES WHO HAVE THAT CAPACITY
TODAY. SO THAT'S HUGE.
WHATEVER YOU HOPE TO DO IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT, IT TAKES A
LONG TIME TO DEVELOP THAT
CAPABILITY. REALLY, I THINK WE
LOOK AT THIS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY. APOLLO WAS ABOUT
TAKING A MAN TO THE MOON AND
RETURNING HIM SAFELY TO EARTH.
AND THAT WAS THE END. WE'RE
DOING SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT
WITH ARTEMIS. WE ARE TRYING TO
BUILD A BLUEPRINT FOR
RESPONSIBLE, SUSTAINED HUMAN
EXPLORATION OF THE SOLAR
SYSTEM, WHICH MEANS WE NEED TO
TAKE OUR TIME WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO SAFETY, AND WE
ALSO NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT
DOING MUCH HARDER THINGS, WHICH
IS SUSTAINING A HUMAN PRESENCE
IN DEEP SPACE. THIS IS NOT
ABOUT A CAMPING TRIP, THIS IS
ACTUALLY ABOUT PUSHING HUMANITY
INTO THE SOLAR SYSTEM. WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THE SPACE STATION
HOW HARD IT IS TO SUSTAIN
PEOPLE IN BASE. IT'S A HUGE
LOGISTICAL PROBLEM. SO FROM OUR
STANDPOINT, WE FEEL LIKE WE
HAVE ALL THE PIECES IN PLACE TO
GO FORWARD WE'RE GOING TO DO IT
METHODICALLY. WE'RE GOING TO
DO IT SAFELY AND WE'RE GOING TO
DO IT FOR THE BENEFIT OF
HUMANITY.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT SPACE
SPACE COULD BE MORE WEAPONIZED?
IT COULD BE YET ANOTHER
PLATFORM FOR MORE I WOULD SAY
THAT NASA IS BOTH CONCERNED,
BUT ALSO DETERMINED NOT TO LET
THOSE THINGS HAPPEN. AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE BUILDING AN
INTERNATIONAL COALITION TO GO
WITH US, ESPECIALLY AS WE PUSH
HUMANITY OUT INTO DEEP SPACE.
FOR RESPONSIBLE SUSTAINED HUMAN
PRESENCE THROUGHOUT THE SOLAR
HER SYSTEM.
>> OKAY, SO BREAK SOME NEWS FOR
US HERE. HOW REALISTIC IS IT?
DO YOU THINK WOULD YOU DREAM OF
FINDING LIFE OUTSIDE AND OFF?
OUR PLAN IS LET ME LET ME JUST
QUOTE A COUPLE OF ASTRONAUTS,
TIM PEAK RECENTLY ON CNBC SAYS
THE JAMES WEBB TELESCOPE MAY
HAVE ALREADY FOUND ALIEN LIFE.
WE FOUND A PLANET THAT SEEMS TO
BE GIVING OFF STRONG SIGNALS OF
BIOLOGICAL LIFE.
>> WELL, I PERSONALLY THINK
IT'S INEVITABLE. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S REALLY BEEN
TRANSFORMATIVE IN PLANETARY
SCIENCE OVER THE LAST TWO OR
THREE DECADES, IS REALIZING
THAT WATER, WHICH IS A CRITICAL
BUILDING BLOCK OF LIFE, IS MUCH
MORE PRESENT EVEN IN OUR SOLAR
SYSTEM THAN WE EVER FOR
IMAGINED. WE THOUGHT ASTEROIDS
WERE DRY BODIES THAT HAD
ABSOLUTELY NO WATER. WE HAD
REAL QUESTIONS EVEN ABOUT THE
MOON. NOW, WE'RE FINDING IT IN
PLACES WE DIDN'T EXPECT SEEING
THOSE BUILDING BLOCKS. AND THEN
OUR RECENT SAMPLE RETURN FROM
THE ASTEROID BENNU SHOWS NOT
JUST WATER BUT CARBON, WHICH IS
ANOTHER CRITICAL BUILDING BLOCK
OF LIFE. SO I THINK IT'S ONLY A
MATTER OF TIME. I LOVE THE FACT
THAT WE'RE FINDING
BIOSIGNATURES POTENTIALLY
THROUGH JAMES WEBB SPACE
TELESCOPE. BUT THEY'RE REAL
BENEFIT AND THE PAYOFF IS GOING
TO BE WHEN WE GO TO MARS AND
SEE IF WE CAN FIND SIGF
LIFE ON OUR NEIGHBOR.
>> WHEN WILL THAT BE?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S HARD TO
KNOW ON THE FRANKLY, WHAT YOU
DON'T KNOW YET. SO WE DO KNOW
THAT IT IS OUR MOST INTERESTING
NEIGHBOR WITH THE HIGHEST
POTENTIAL TO FALL FIND SIGNS OF
LIFE. SO AS FAR AS HUMAN
PRESENCE GOES, WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO SET UP A BLUEPRINT
AND WE'RE GOING TO PRACTICE IT
ON THE MOON. BUT I'D LIKE TO
SEE US HEAD TO MARS, I THINK
WITH OUR PLAN BY THE EARLY
2040s, NOW WHEN YOU TALKED
ABOUT APOLLO, YOU SAID HIS
THE MOON AND BRING HIM BACK
SAFELY THAT WAS NOT LOST ON ME.
ARE YOU THERE HAS BEEN NO WOMAN
WALKING ON THE MOON. AND I
WONDER WHAT YOU THOUGHT, WHAT
IS YOUR JOURNEY TO THE STARS,
SO TO SPEAK, WHAT INSPIRED YOU
AS A YOUNG GIRL?
>> WELL, I WAS TOTALLY INSPIRED
BY THE APOLLO PROGRAM. AND
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS, AS I
HAVE PROGRESSED THROUGH MY
CAREER, THE NUMBER OF
SCIENTISTS, PILOTS, ENGINEERS
THAT I'VE MET WHO WERE ALSO
INSPIRED BY THE APOLLO PROGRAM
>> FOR MAN SO, WHAT IS EXCITING
TO ME IS TO SEE THAT
>> OUR ARTEMIS CAMPAIGN, I
BELIEVE IS GOING TO UNLEASH A
TIDAL WAVE OF YOUNG PEOPLE
INTEE
EXPLORATION. AND THIS TIME
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN ALL
AROUND IN THE WORLD. AND I'M
PRETTY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
>> AND HOW DID YOU GET INTO
THIS BUSINESS
>> WELL, BACK IN THE DAY, THE
ONLY ASTRONAUTS THAT I KNEW
ABOUT WHERE MILITARY JET TEST
PILOTS. SO BEING A LITTLE
STUBBORN, I DECIDED THAT'S WHAT
I WAS GOING TO DO TO EVEN
THOUGH WOMEN WERE NOT ACTUALLY
ALLOWED TO FLY YET, IN THE
MILITARY BUT I WAS VERY
FORTUNATE. I WAS BORN EXACTLY
AT THE RIGHT TIME. I THINK
CHRISTIANE, I FEEL VERY
FORTUNATE THAT THE DOORS OPEN
JUST JUST AHEAD OF ME ALLOWING
WOMEN TO FLY JETS IN THE AIR
FORCE, ALLOWING ME TO BECOME A
TEST PILOT AND THAT WAS MY
PROGRESSION TO BECOMING AN
ASTRONAUT.
>> BEST PILOT, IT SOUNDS SO
COOL AND DANGEROUS AND SCARY
AND TOP GUNNY AND PHON AND